bonjour antoine la situation continue de
se détériorer en russie mais moscou
place ses espoirs dans la mise sur sur
le marché prochainement de son premier
vaccin
oui tout à fait les autorités russes ont
soumis une demande d'enregistrement
accéléré et de préqualification de son
premier vaccin le spoutnik v auprès de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'objectif le rendre accessible au plus
grand nombre ce dans les délais les plus
brefs possibles car en effet comme un
peu partout en europe
chaque nouvelle journée vient battre les
records de la veille
autant en termes de nouvelles
contaminations que de décès concrètement
ces dernières 24 heures plus de 16 mille
nouveaux cas ont été identifiés et 346
décès ont été constatés et cela pourrait
pousser les autorités à prendre des
mesures fortes
après les recommandations d'hier
concernant la fermeture des bars et
restaurants entre 23 heures et 6 heures
du matin interrogé sur la possibilité
d'un possible reconfirme ans et de ses
conséquences sur l'économie
voici ce qu'a répondu le porte-parole du
kremlin écouter il n'y a qu'une seule
décision fondamentale et le président en
a parlé
il s'agit de la sécurité de la santé des
gens c'est ça la décision fondamentale
qui reste au premier plan en ce qui
concerne tout le reste
l'état-major opérationnel fonctionne les
régions poursuivent leur travail
les décisions sont prises en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation
mais comme nous le disons actuellement
et nous l'avons répété plusieurs fois
les mesures qui ont été prises
précédemment nous permettre d'être
beaucoup plus sûrs de nous que pendant
les mois précédents mais il ne faut pas
oublier que la situation en russie est
loin d'être homogène comme l'a rappelé
vladimir poutine certaines régions
commencent tout juste à être
véritablement frappé par la pandémie
écouter on ne parle pas d'une deuxième
vague
nous en avons discuté tout récemment ce
matin selon les experts certaines
régions commencent seulement à faire
face à la première vague
il faut suivre de près l'évolution de la
situation et réagir rapidement et de
manière efficace
man qui se déroule un recond finement
massif et général n'est pour l'instant
pas à l'ordre du jour en russie
d'une part parce que on viens de
l'entendre la situation varie beaucoup
d'une région à l'autre même si elle est
globalement sous contrôle mais aussi
pour éviter ses conséquences
dévastatrices sur l'économie merci
beaucoup en clair depuis moscou en
russie